le dossier barbie avec tout d'abord
cette incidence sur le travail des juges
d'instruction de lyon ils ont protesté
aujourd'hui contre le surcroît de
travail qui leur est imposé par la
récente suppression du tribunal
permanent des forces armées c'est ainsi
que le juge christian riss qui doit
conduire le dossier
barbie a par ailleurs sur son bureau 112
dossiers de cet ancien tribunal qui
s'ajoutent aux 120 qui l'avait déjà à
instruire et il n'y a que dix juge
d'instruction à lyon
quant au fait de savoir maintenant si le
procès barbie doit être ou non télévisé
il semble que l'on ne se dirige pas vers
une exception pour barbie pour le
tortionnaire de lyon mais dès ce matin
une commission a eu une première réunion
pour examiner le principe d'une
intrusion de la télévision dans les
prétoires et le garde des sceaux robert
badinter a donné son point de vue à
michèle perrot
ce n'est pas une commission destinée à
préparer une décision concernant le
procès barbie ce serait inadmissible
qu'on se mette à légiférer ou à prendre
des décisions réglementaires a proposé
un procès est en particulier c'est un
problème beaucoup plus vaste et la
sphère barbie c'est une affaire parmi
d'autres s'y lie à une modification de
la loi
elle vaudra pour le croient seuls
arbitres mais elle vaudra aussi bien
pour toutes les autres à faire envoyer
c'est un problème général
j'ai toujours aussi été sensible au fait
que historiquement nous n'avons pas les
éléments que nous aurions pu conserver
quel dommage que l'on n'ait pas la voix
de léon blum au procès pétain
quel dommage qu'on n'entende pas laval
au début de son procès se défendant lui
même
quel dommage qu'on n'ait pas conservé
l'enregistrement du choléra recouvre dû
penser les barricades
enfin les archives judiciaires sont
vides parce que l'on ne sait pas assez
soucié de voir comment l'on pourrait
réussir à conserver des documents
sonores ou visuelles suffisant